good evening everyone
from the sunken garden at trafford town
hall
the first thing i have to do is thank
councillor rob chilton for all his hard
work as mayor these last 18 months
apart from being the chair of school
governors
chair of sales civic society and others
he's been involved in
many organizations he volunteered to
help the distribution of food parcels
during the lockdown he completed so many
engagements
he may well have set a record people ask
why do we have the meralty answer the
main function of the mayor ramirez
is to thank all the volunteers who work
tirelessly
throughout this the year helping others
in the metropolitan borough
of trafford rob has done this so often
himself
he is expertly pleased to thank our
volunteers
he has truly lived up to the title of
first citizen
of the borough and for myself i have
lived and worked in trafford
all my life to become the mayor amerus
is a great honor for me and my wife
rachel
if it is possible to have an ambition
from our time as mayor and maris
it is for trafford to become a more
caring more tolerant
of all its people father gerald murphy
from saint anthony of pardue in
stratford
will act as my chaplain and i am
grateful to him and the parish
for their support my chosen charities
are the trafford food banks
and gauss hill studios i think not to be
able to feed your family
must be a dive devastating experience
and i applaud all the work the food
banks do to remedy this
it is some years ago that i volunteered
to work with youth activities
with young people from old trafford gas
hill studios were willing to help me
with this
and i have had a connection with them
ever since they continue to go above and
beyond
with their support for young people
i hope everyone can support my
fundraising activities
for these two charities through the next
18 months
there is a great deal of background work
that goes into the office of merote
and i have had a chance to see all the
officers in action
since i have been deputy mayor i
continue to be grateful
for all their work and patience which if
it didn't happen
the morality would not be able to
function
a huge thank you to all our officers
and can i finish we live in strange
times because of the pandemic
but these strange times will not last
forever we will get through this and i'm
sure by the end of my 18 months
term of office we will have become
stronger
and more caring of our fellow citizens
in trafford
thank you everybody and we hope you have
an enjoyable
annual general meeting this evening
thank you
lord of wisdom
we ask your blessing upon lawrence walsh
as mayor during this year and on all
the members of trafford council
teach us all to walk in your ways so
that our actions
may give you glory may we desire to
witness to others
your love so that they may draw closer
to you
take from us whatever hinders us
from adhering to your word
creating us that desire to serve others
and in doing so to serve you
lord our world desperately needs models
of truth and integrity
people of honor who attest their lives
to your goodness
may we always seek to be persons who
inspire others to faithful obedience of
that
which jesus taught us
help our council leaders to follow those
who've begun this good work
those men and women who before us were
determined to advance
jesus mission of healing the teaching of
caring for the poor
guide us to be your light
so that we may all witness to others
your truth and your life and we ask this
through jesus christ our lord
amen and so may almighty god bless you
in keeping his love in his care
and help you to become the people you
can be
and the blessing of the father and the
son
and the holy spirit amen